how long until you're retired and you're
a full-time chef
yeah
man i just i love it i love that i like
it
obviously i'm not the best cooker but i
love it i cook a mean steak though yeah
i cook a [ __ ] good steak you just
come back from a good steak uh action
bronzer just took us for for good steak
it was actually really sick yeah it was
really good how long are you how long
are you guys in town for oh we leave
after this oh here's the last one yeah
you should have hit me man yeah what are
you going to do
yeah i would have got you guys some good
rezzies yeah stay one more night maybe
go to a place
oh okay where are you here we are
where's next
l.a okay
okay
yeah yeah we'll we'll organize something
for you yeah what is it what is your
least favorite food least favorite food
yeah like you do not eat it
oh [ __ ] i eat anything man i'll eat
everything yeah he he'll eat anything
dude didn't he hear his stories
that's the next episode of cooking with
volkswagen yeah that would be fire would
have chopped
vegetables obviously you need the
vegetables yeah yeah but i mean you
could
when i'm in camp because i've got to eat
[ __ ] loads of vegetables yeah and a lot
of times it's all it's like already
packaged and all that ready yeah so you
just got to just force it down yeah so
that's something that uh like again you
can obviously if you do
vegetables right it's all good but
yeah sometimes you get over it just give
me a steak
salad you've got to translate your
veggies you need your greens
yeah something what do you like say
again
cilantro i can't [ __ ] eat it's
absolutely disgusting i love it dude i
don't get it cilantro we call that uh
parsley yeah no no no that's parsley
that's a different thing yeah that's
parsley
what are we called by cilantro no you
guys call it um [ __ ] there's another
name for it it's called coriander or
something
coriander is it coriander yeah coriander
yeah that's what we're called yes yeah
but uh pasta
is it um
no i love that yeah i love that i can't
a lot of people ask about the pineapple
and pizzas what do you like with that
why you don't i like it i don't know why
it's such a big we're a little bougie
with our pizza here in new york it's
actually not that bad i think new
yorkers are kind did you have good pizza
when you're here yeah i did yeah okay
where'd you go well yeah you probably
yeah it's obviously just a tourist thing
yeah we went full tours we went to joe's
pizza no
we're not in new york when it comes to
pizza there's a reason why it's touristy
is because it's that good okay joe's is
the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah man like yeah it
is good 100 is good whatever it is one
of the best you can uh yeah i think it's
one of the best in the city
there's some other places that are also
good it was good yeah yeah now the thing
is like i'm always worried because
it's like pizza can't be that bad but it
also can't be
that great you know how like a steak can
you can bite into steak you're like holy
[ __ ] what is going on here whereas like
pizza kind of operates in this range
even if you do frozen pizza you're like
it's pretty [ __ ] good solid it's
solid right so i i always worry that
people come here going i'm about to have
the best pizza in my life and they're
like i'll be disappointed because
they're expectations they put to it's
bread cheese and sauce at the end of the
day yeah i'm hearing i know i know
exactly what you're saying but [ __ ] your
pizza was good it was good it was good
i've had it a couple of times anyway so
but i know it's good but i mean it's
good yeah i love yeah i love pizza and
but i mean i don't i don't even usually
like thin pizza yeah i like thick crust
usually what time is it
[Laughter]
i promise i swear i've never done that
as well they are not my stories the
leech is mine
just remember how many you're gonna edit
that out anyway bye
[Laughter]
all of your teammates are gonna dm me
pictures of you drinking your own piss
guaranteed from random mondays full of
[ __ ] it's gonna be doing a bubble
[Applause]